out of sight but I'm really happy with
it
so
in the previous part we talked only
about join queries now we're going to
increase the expressivity a little bit
and the first thing we're going to do is
add existential variables add
projections
so let's talk about conjunctive queries
and see what happens
now what's a conjunctive query this is a
joint query that we saw before in a
conjunctive query we're also allowed to
make some of the variables existential
so here we will just not when we write
the query we would just not put with
some of the variables in the head of the
query and this would mean that this
variable is supposed to be existential
now if you look at the this the list of
answers the set of answers it just means
that you basically remove this column
and then you remove duplicates
okay
these are the type of queries we want to
answer
so how can we do that of course we don't
want to just produce produce this big
list of answers and remove the
duplicates because we spend a lot of
time on producing all of the answers
time that might not be proportional
proportional to the actual output we
have
so
let's look at this query for example we
want to join these relations over here
and then we want to project to only key
to to make X existential right
so this was the list of answers before
now we make X existential and we have
less answers
the algorithm or a suggestion for an
algorithm here would be to do the same
things we did before find a joint free
remove the dangling tuples and then
let's see what happens if we just ignore
the parts with the existential variables
so we have this part of the tree that's
everything that doesn't contain X let's
try to join those and simply ignore the
relation that has X
on this specific example you can see
that it works right we joined the two
things we have there we get exactly the
right output
now let's look at the different example
and you can guess that uh
there so we have the same query but a
different projection now Y is
existential instead of x
uh if we look at the parts
sorry now Z that is existential instead
of x if we look at the parts that don't
contain Z
um and we we just ignore everything else
and try to join those we'll get that the
number of answers like there are six
answers it's like a Cartesian product of
the two things we have left and that's
more than what we have here
so what happens is we basically lost
some information about what is allowed
to go with what
because before we knew that W1 is also
allowed to go only allowed to go with Z1
and Z1 is only allowed to go with y1 so
we won't get answers where W1 goes with
these but now we don't have this
information anymore so we can't do the
this algorithm this trick on this query
is this query harder than the previous
one
yes
uh and the way we Define it so we have
this sort of extension so before we said
that extensional definition from from
before this is an acyclic query and an
acyclic query is also free conics if we
have a connected part of the joint tree
that contains exactly the three
variables and then we can do what we did
before
ignore everything that's outside of this
connected part and then because it's
connected we don't lose the information
on what to go with
uh so this is almost the correct
definition if I don't want to lie to you
I need to also tell you that this query
is also called free connects because we
are allowed to add nodes that are
subsets of other nodes to make the query
connected but we won't go into these
details in the future the important
thing is that you have the interaction
we had with
okay let's keep this slide so dichotomy
if the query is a cyclic freakonics we
have an algorithm
if the query is cyclic the same proof we
mentioned before still works to prove
that it's hard
what happens if the query is a cyclic
but not reconnects then it is hard but
for another reason we can show that it's
hard if we assume the hardness of
Boolean matrix multiplication
this is an example for like the most
basic query that's a cyclic version of
free conics and
um let's assume we want to multiply
these two Boolean matrices
we encode the two matrices in our two
relations so we look at the places where
we have ones we look at the row and
column indices and put them for the
first Matrix in the first relation for
the second Matrix in the second relation
and then the square by definition
computes the positions of the ones in
the output
you can see this for example because the
one in index 1 2 can be explained by the
ones and indexes one two and two
so if you can answer the square with
linear pre-processing where the size of
your input is at most n square and
constant delay where the size of the
output is almost N squared
then you solved Boolean matrix
multiplication in quadratic time
now you can see that this captures the
idea that the hardness comes from having
to remove duplicates because the ones in
the output can be explained sometimes in
different ways but we're not allowed to
go over all of the explanations for them
just over all the actual output
so whenever we can always do this
reduction for any query that's a cyclic
but not reconics because for every query
that is typically but not reconics we
have something similar to what we have
here where we have this sort of path
so x y z so X Y appear in an atom why is
that appear in an atom but x and z don't
appear in an atom and the end points are
free but the middle is not free and
whenever this happens we can do this
okay let's keep this yeah that itself
during this case oh I didn't say that
yes set of joint free for self joins we
don't know we're confused even for
joints we put them aside and now I
assume everything is self-jointed yes
okay
now let's continue to unions of
conjunctive chords
uh what's the union of good Young's
Aquarius well it's a union of
conjunctive queries
so we have let's say two conjunctive
queries it could be more in general we
want the unions of the answers to the
individual
um so some of the answers can be answers
to both some of them can be answers to
one uh we want the union of all of those
what can happen in terms of the
complexity
so the first case is that all queries in
the union are easy
in this case it's not very complicated
to show that the union itself will
always also be easy
let's keep the details and talk about
the more interesting parts
the second part is that some queries in
the union are easy and some queries in
the Union
and it was actually thought before that
if this Union is non-redundant then a
union that contains a hard query is
always hard
but this turned out to be wrong and this
Union can sometimes be hard but
sometimes be easy this is quite
surprising when we found this out
and then at this point because we like
dichotomy we wanted to prove that
everything for which we don't have an
algorithm
is always hard and in particular we
wanted to prove that the third case
is always oh I'm jumping ahead
okay so I'll give you the overview and
then go back so we wanted to prove that
the third case is always hard we try to
prove it and our proof only works for
most cases but not for all of them and
then at some point we realize the reason
we what we wanted we wouldn't we weren't
able to prove it is because what we were
trying to prove is wrong so even a union
that only contains higher queries can
sometimes be easy and this is really
nice because what we did is we're trying
to prove conditional lower bounds and we
found algorithms because we failed like
we found that there were some cases
where we can do things more efficiently
um
so that was awesome okay let's talk
about the second case now in a bit more
detail
uh
so remember this was the way we proved
hardness for a query that's a cyclic but
not frequent using Boolean matrix
multiplication
now what happens if such a query is part
of a union
this is a query that's just a bit more
complicated than what we saw before we
can do the same type of reduction work
the same construction here and in R3 in
w we just put constants
so this still finds us the answers to
matrix multiplication
but if this query is part of a union
then if we assume that the query is easy
we don't just get the answers to the
first query definition here we get the
answers to the entire Union over this
construction Q2 has a lot of answers a
cubic number of answers
so solving the query efficiently doesn't
compute matrix multiplication
efficiently so it doesn't contradict the
assumption
so the hardness results don't hold when
the conjunction queries are within a
union
and the query we saw right now is
actually easy uh the way we show it's
easy
uh is because you can notice that the
hard parts of q1
is exactly what Q2 computes Q2 computes
the join of R1 and R2
and since we have this body homomorphism
so Q2 doesn't have extra atoms that
don't appear in q1
what Q2 computes here this join is not
filtered on top of what we want so we
don't lose information
and Q2 is really just exactly the joint
of R1
so what we can do is after we compute Q2
we can look at the list of answers treat
it as another relation and then extend
q1 with an extra atom that uses this
and now this extended query is free
conics
this almost shows us what we want
um
because what it gives us is
well first of all we can have duplicates
we can have the same answer twice and we
have this sort of linear pre-processing
for entering q1 after we already started
producing answers so that's not
something we want but we can very easily
uh like go
work with that make it work uh using
something we like to call the cheaters
Lemma because it tells us how much we're
allowed to cheat without really cheating
yes
isn't the case that q1 is contained
uh no because of the three variables
because why
you can see that the the three variables
are in different positions
that's a good point so it's only a body
homomorphism it's not a complete
homomorphism which is why which is
exactly the confusion that made people
think that a union that contains a hard
query is necessarily always hard okay so
this was the proof that turned out
okay
um so the cheaters learn how to tell us
how much we're allowed to cheat
we're allowed to have a usually constant
delay but a constant number of the
linear delay steps and almost no
duplicates but every value will return a
constant number of times and we can sort
of
uh save the answers we've seen and not
print the same answer twice and then
withhold the answers a bit to regularize
the delay and we get linear reprocessing
constantly
escaping aside
and now when we get to the third case
Union
of hard queries that can become easy
this can only happen in very limited
cases and the cases are that the queries
are basically body isomorphic it's
basically the same query but with
different projections so this way both
queries can help each other
but the hard parts of the queries are
different because of different
projections
um so only the high level idea
we cannot find all answers to q1
efficient but we could find some answers
to q1 efficiently and we can show that
we can find exactly the right answers to
compute the hard part of Q2 so the join
of R3 and R4 bowtie is something that
symbolizes choice
so after we find some answers of the
queue of q1 we have enough information
to help Q2 and then after we if we
computed Q2 we can use that to help q1
again
yeah
when I ask
Ed by analogy analogy suppose I didn't
want to uh enumerate I just wanted to
detect then for example we know that a
graph either has a large enough
Independence or a large enough click any
graph right so the ore of the two is
there an independent set of size 10 or
an or a Clifford size 10 is actually
very easy to do and basically linear
time so is this analogous to why this is
easy
like a Ramsey theoretic sort of thing I
think so
because I think that that's interesting
to think about but I think the case you
described now would be
would hold within the algorithm We have
basically of Union extension so if we
have
a union we we describe this as a union
of two queries we will have that the
independent set query
that's a cyclic
oh right this is right right plus yeah
classifications
but you can create a negated
relationship yeah but then you
say something about how do you think
I think that you need an example of the
Union there is a path of length too or
there is a path City
I was just wondering about
protection okay
so for detection I mean if you just want
a oh but if it's a union of two hard
things
okay we're short of time so think about
it but I really do want to think about
it
so
for unions also open problem what we do
know is for unions of two conjunctive
queries
and for Union of two conjunctive queries
um if we have what we call Union
extensions or algorithms work it works
if it doesn't work we remain we managed
to show that there's always a reduction
but for this we had to use vertex and
balanced triangle detection and I say
hard to use is because we sort of show
that it's unavoidable if we want to
classify all your cqs uh because what we
show is well if vertex and balance
triangle detection holds we have a
dichotomy but if it doesn't hold then we
get an algorithm for some ucq unions of
projective query that we don't currently
know of an algorithm for
um so uh
have an example for why we have to use
or like we why we had to use uh this and
couldn't use the previous assumptions
but maybe we'll skip that yeah I think
we we have to finish
uh and then for going Beyond two
conjunctive queries in the Union
we don't know and we have a specific
open problem
um so this query if you want to try to
classify if it's easy or hard to enter I
can show it to you again and explain to
this
and see what happens
and we'll finish here
a quick question before we go on a
15-minute break
so maybe I just I mean I didn't say a
conclusion but let me just say
so we only went up two units of
conjunctive queries uh there are other
things we can add like negation like
this qualities like Aggregates like
things that will come in the next days
like recursion and updates and whatever
we didn't talk about that at all and
also we didn't talk about what happens
when we can't do linear pre-processing
how much pre-processing we need or if we
want to increase the delay what happens
in these cases
what happens if you do vaccinematics we
had in the in the boot camp we have
developed about 70 rings and of course
at the center yeah then then it should
be easy if it's a cyclic because it's
just like enumerating the join right and
then not printing some of the variables
itself
well if it's cyclic you can't even find
the first answer in linear time so
well I cyclic non-free connects becomes
easy but because of algorithms we know
for joints and the harness result for
cyclic queries carries over
um
understanding correctly all of the
hardness rules are saying even for the
first answer you're in trouble
uh no for the Boolean match the one that
rely on Boolean matrix multiplication
they say we need everything and we
cannot do that and then uh what I didn't
explain this but for the cycling case
there's also an alternative reduction
that's based on zero click and then also
you need to talk about the total time
all right okay so let's take a break and
learn 15 and back from Android link is
[Applause]